[Music]
this is Nick right here oh let me go
it's hurt what you up to yeah I'm
reading Samaras - kiddo Cole Cole Cole
Cole Cole Cole note that was so listen
man that time Kobe is back we got
hammered off party liquor spread-eagle I
made you promise that if I was ever
super hot super intelligent being a
newbie as moral standing you to whisk me
away into an exotic land well then you'd
come and help brother out no promises
that's like a sacred pact man her look
and whatever you need wait till tomorrow
I'm gonna go with the big NO on that
compadre is one of them live for dad
things fed up sometimes came out of it
you know Paula mouth alright I'll help
where do you need me to go
[ __ ] does that mean what hold on try not
to vomit Oh
is going on
is
oh you gotta be kidding me
[Music]
favor stability critical system
stability critical
[Music]
oh my - go to work but I hope that suits
all shape too much what are the hell's
going on perk her where are you relax
man everything's fine
well not exactly fine the situation is a
rather dire but just head through the
doors man I'll explain everything in a
minute
[Music]
what we're doing here look man okay
there ain't always a logical explanation
of these things sometimes you just find
yourself like in a space station with
little of no context or backstory you
just got a [ __ ] wrong with it man so
less questions and more movement nicolas
cuz you don't save us we all know that
me what the [ __ ] are you talking about
I swear to god I'm gonna whoop your ass
when I see you oh man dude I'm so happy
to see you too now I know what you're
thinking where's my junk but as
important as the answer is to that
question we got bigger fish to fry
firstly let me explain what's going on
you are now on Mars welcome
now imagine my arms are outstretched to
comfort you the jury said revelation why
are you on Mars to save the earth man
what from an alien invasion
yeah that's right man an alien invasion
you go now I'm gonna keep it 100 weeks
yet it's not gonna be us who are doing
the actual saving of Earth it's gonna be
mostly and that and the AI super being
that Larry Parker would not stop talking
about you remember only problem is man
these aliens took over the entire planet
they mess with her Network man and she
has come undone and we need to get her
back so how do we return an to this
beautiful majestic earth-saving
butterfly she once was by finding an
energy cores and using them to power up
all the terminals in the network man
it's a simple plan don't worry
gotta get moving though man there's a
couple energy core thing he's over
yonder man I'll show you how this works
go get him
energy cores alien invasion what the
[ __ ]
[Music]
so you brought me all the way to Mars to
turn the power back on control center
restored their warp see Nick this and
and be my bro Nick hi Nicholas right you
are last hope and me to wrap an arachnid
foursome millions of years in the making
threatens your world but with your help
I can stop them yeah Herc filled me in
on that part we turn on the terminals
and restore your power and stop the
alien invasion is there anything I'm
missing here yeah why do you ask
I don't know just seems pretty simple
for me something not so simple you think
there be more to it no it is very
straightforward okay man all systems are
a go let's get down to business
you're gonna need to be able to defend
yourself out here
you see the green bales around here grab
what's inside when you're done man take
some of your space jizz over that 3d
print machine over there and I'll show
you a cool trick
voila MIGO welcome to the place where
all your wildest dreams come true
current designs are limited the lure you
restore me the more blueprints I can
retrieve from the database
[Music]
[Music]
here that works man space years equals
firearms
yes
[Music]
systems are restored the more tools I
can provide to obliterate any and all
life forms who stand in our way
uh what do you mean all life forms oh
you'll see what we get outside we yeah
man I ain't gonna let you hog all the
glory for saving the world this here's a
partnership now come on grab my head
dude got work to do man this is not
happening
get a grip Nicholas cuz your brains
about to go kablooey man outside we go
[Music]
scattered across the landscape turning
them on will help restore my
functionality and help you on your
journey
relax man it's just Mars you know
wait-wait-wait man stay on back to space
crab man shoot it shoot it please don't
drop me
[Music]
[Applause]
watch out there's more come on Nick I
know you can do it buddy we can't find
the other energy cores unless we power
the antenna [ __ ] me I gotta climb towers
now look man some stuff ain't as
advanced out here as a Montana for which
I apologize okay
I totally forgot to mention those space
crabs they live underground that that
one's all me man I'm so sorry that's my
bad you're sorry you want to tell me
what that was all about man hey you ever
seen tremors these space crab dudes they
tear through dirt the exact same way I'm
telling you man I hope you got a good
look man cuz they're the invaders okay
they're the ones we need to stop it was
telling me they're gonna use her
technology to invade the earth and turn
all the humans into food isn't that
crazy
exactly few minutes will become nothing
more than food to sustain the arachnid
hoard as it spreads through the galaxy
are you sure
because I mean they don't look all that
smart to me
well they are these little bastards
they've been playing keep-away with the
energy core so and can't get back online
so we're gonna get those energy cores
back you can bet that these little
bastards are gonna be all in our face
about it
it's working
antennae restored
excellent snack thank you for your
assistance you may now consult your map
to locate other energy cores in this
area
[Music]
oh man those two blips right there that
looks like the spot where I was attacked
by a big-ass space crab I am picking up
a signal from your gravity belt nearby
it will improve mobility remove fall
damage and allow you to reach the
transference center no no way my space
chess is still working dude dude my
space jets are still working okay let's
go find the man once you acquire the
gravity belt go to the transference
center
what the hell's transference
transference is the future
it's plugging my consciousness into a
robot killing machine like I'm at 2:09
transference it's the future yeah yeah
we get it in oh man she's been trying to
make me forget about finding my human
body so I just live life in a robot body
but I got a good feeling ma'am staying
positive
disengaging door look please wait
oh dang is that is that my hand well who
else's hand would it be dummy fair point
man I'm just not mentally prepared to
accept the possibility that something
really bad has happened to my childless
dad bottom my scans indicate several
more organic anomalies oh come on you
serious
my body's in a bunch of pieces oh man
I'll go find them all with transference
you'll gain the ability to detect such
anomaly as yourself
done and done
here and now another promise is made we
will find my body parts and put me back
together like Humpty Dumpty cuz there
ain't no point in saving a world that
does not include my beautiful be unhappy
you will comply transference is the
future
okay just like Ian said we need to find
the spaceships I was used to get the
Transfer Center without it watch your
step man and remember the sand is bad
damn looks like the energy cores are up
there
need to find those space jets
oh she that's my pelvic area big ass
space crab didn't be dirty
[Music]
you